en las afueras del suroeste de mariupol
nuevas imágenes de satélite parecen
contar una historia desgarradora
maksar technologies publicó el jueves un
conjunto de fotos que muestran lo que
serían más de 200 fosas comunes en el
pueblo de manus las imágenes con fecha
entre finales de marzo y principios de
abril subir en una expansión gradual de
las tumbas de un cementerio existente el
ayuntamiento de mariupol cree que hasta
nueve mil cuerpos pueden haber sido
arrojados allí por el ejército ruso
solo hay una carretera de circunvalación
desde la ciudad de manus hay una
gasolinera poco a la izquierda y un
viejo cementerio detrás de ella y un
campus cerca de este cementerio
en este campo hay una enorme zanja de 30
metros de largo donde están llevando a
nuestros ciudadanos en enormes camiones
todos esos ciudadanos nuestros hombres
están siendo asesinados por la
federación rusa
aunque el gobierno ucraniano aún no ha
confirmado las acusaciones no ha habido
respuesta inmediata de moscú los ojos
del kremlin siguen fijados en la propia
mariupol tras haber declarado el jueves
la victoria en la seguridad de la acedia
la ciudad portuaria sin embargo sigue
existiendo una pequeña resistencia de la
milicia ucraniana estimada en dos mil
combatientes refugiados en la planta de
acero de azov tal así como una serie de
túneles de conexión y búnkers
subterráneos se han atrincherado con
alrededor de un millar de civiles el
ejército ruso en lugar de asaltar la
enorme planta ha decidido privar a los
que están dentro de recursos vitales
pidiendo su rendición
y el infierno es lo que está sucediendo
en mariupol no es posible simplemente
contarlo los rusos están matando a la
gente por nada según las funcionarias
ucranianos el jueves no se pude evacuar
a más residentes ya que las fuerzas
rusas continuaron bombardeando los
corredores humanitarios acordados